welcome to this 15-minute game d for now
let's let's fianchetto this bishop and
decide later what what exactly to do so
Kings Indian most most of the time this
leads to interesting interesting battles
so P doesn't exchange on e5 and
fortunately it didn't on d5 on black sub
two principal moves are a 5 or 9 a-6 a5
is the the tested the test at mainline
ready but not a success some an
interesting alternative so on what now
yeah why does some probably threatening
before so I need to react with a 5 seem
so seems best Bishop h6 is also on also
possible a team I'm not sure maybe he
can reply before anyway sometimes this
is possible before Bishop d to recapture
and just sacrifice a form for the two
bishops and the dark squares so okay
let's play a five and ten make sure that
damn
this night is secure on c5 this looks
like a very weakening move more than one
idea bishop age 6 the certain do one way
to to play all night h5 both are looking
good let's start start with this night
age 52 f form also preparing the usual
king's indian movie at five so on i
could take all be 6 p-6 also on seems
fine let's play b6 the ideas simply oh
just a second I was intending beat xe5
but he takes us also also not bad okay
let's keep it simple so I want to be
sure that form an idea for Bishop f4
also would be nice more f5 f5 also
possible come on let's go f5
so blacks got down this typical play on
the King side and high temperatures he
wants to prevent f4 it seems Lex got
this typical play on the King side but
there's some structure on the queenside
with the taking on c5 and B takes d5 I
think helps black to worm would use
whites play here yeah so what now normal
move for white would be on something
like Queen to d2 connecting Ruxin
connecting rooks and then maybe I'm
preparing and let's say Bishop g5 almost
like that so what now I mean f4
certainly very committal and probably
not so great it gives up the foursquare
and adam gap it tries to deliver
checkmate on the G file but it's very
committal I don't really have don't
really like it f form maybe I'm just
improve the position somewhat more and
not sure if F for so it smooth that
wider to play it really weakens the dark
squares a lot after night f4 Bishop f4
years I've got a very strong bishop but
it also um gives me a very big f thorn
okay I'll play a non-committal move
first and then see then see then see em
how to how to proceed the special be
seven should be useful and lots of
scenarios yeah white handsome some
typical strengthening moves as well the
a1 rook has various moves like Group B 1
rupee one get out of this diagonal
sometimes this is useful and the long
run it's not so clear what worldwide
some general plan is in this position a
3 before attacking on the queenside this
is really slow it's not easy to to
realize and in the center it's also also
not easy maybe f4 but this is really
really a committal move f 49 f for
Bishop f4 he takes a foreign jump yeah
maybe Queen takes but that this bishop
on g7 is so strong it's it's hard to
believe that this would be good for wide
the bishop on g7 is simply so much
better than the knight on c3 so I cannot
cannot really believe that f4 is good
good for white I move like Bishop to to
g5 I can answer in various ways the
Queen e8 is one move intending Queen g6
which would be also good square for the
Queen
I'm not sure maybe I was I was thinking
about to move like King to h1 but it's
really doing nothing this move and maybe
even um we've run into some some moves
like a queen edge form yeah this I also
briefly thought about but it looks so
weakening hard to believe let's say it's
it's a move I mean I thought about this
but I couldn't really couldn't really
believe that it is so it should be any
good yeah so I'm what's my reply night
air force the the obvious obvious move
but hmm I take first and then neither
for him can try to really grab this pawn
I mean it looks it looks really really
dangerous to do it but he could take on
f4 twice yeah just nodded from this must
be okay Bishop f4 he takes a for Queen
air forever I'm capture on g4 with tempo
and the therm a big big position from
like so you cannot take twice on air for
now
yeah maybe you can take on f5 now but at
the end time there will always be a
bishop on if on e5 on d4 enter it it
looks it looks just disastrous ok so
what first bishop default check probably
the bishop is simply a monster piece so
on I can always take at five and it's
not it's not clear if I if I must must
do it now also the question is look at
five or Bishop f5 look at five can can
easily be a good move like Queen to
Queen to h4 h5 something like that no
that's nuts let's go for this yeah if i
go to h5 now here can take a form well
now we cannot let special b5 coming yes
still it looks a little bit shaky
I can always play Bishop e3 in inserting
inserting this move and then move the
rock to age 54 for example as let's do
that let us protect the F porn some
don't need to worry about Queen takes a
force now or is there something better I
mean it looks like they're there should
be a more than one good move the
episodes it must be alright h7 is the
tech but I could I could also play group
g5 for example to show page 17a Jade I
mean no cares about the edge porn now
however as good as it looks um it's not
clear if black is really winning
probably this position love still has
some defensive resources for wide yeah
Bishop back here might cannot
allow him to take this this piece Maya
oh this come on a group takes h2 isn't
this this must be winning okay yeah come
on this must be winning and I didn't
calculate this till the end but this
this must be winning no way that white
can survive this okay Pusha page freeze
not winning okay it's close though it's
close gag and give a check on g3 and
take a three but so not clear that this
is this is winning at least done I don't
see it
one one possibility is just to to move
the king and get rook g8 into the mix
but um don't see when maybe I'm just
just blind here until possible well I
can always always give this check
without any negative side effects and
always return to h4 if I don't don't see
a win at the moment I don't see a win
probably this is really embarrassing
that I don't see a win here but I simply
don't I don't see how how this this is
winning yeah probably I probably I need
to I need the the rukon age 18 and some
in some way I take f3 I can always do
that maybe it is helpful because um I i
get there at the g four square so Nyjah
Knight to g4 is not not on as the
defensive booth maybe he came check
again so now there's no Knight g4 that's
not a 4 however as a possible defense ok
what about this I give the check now and
he's going to if he goes to g1 is in the
pin so i have bishop h3y are just the
king move with rob g eight and so on if
he goes to g2 i can i can play em play
every check and it's this is this the
way to go he needs to take and then I've
got rook f8 also clingy to rook f2
yeah this is winning so let's throw this
check in so kingi to rogue afterwards
when he have I didn't see I went on King
g2 yet maybe just bishop f2 but ok this
is this is so really a clear clear one
it's just a hailstorm of of checks and
King see wonders bishop you three and
this is also mopping up if I fire up the
computer i probably will tell me how how
to how to win this much much easier
let's let's have a look I'm really
curious what I played didn't really seem
like well the computer doesn't want to
take I know it wants to take it and
gives me plus 60 at least this is a
winning move ok I I took and yeah yeah I
played the computer line nice and now it
gives us check exactly and this winds to
Jesse yet so I played the plate the best
lon yeah I didn't expect this it
certainly looked like that there should
be I don't know something something
better the computer actually points out
night age three here again I didn't
didn't think about this move but I can
simply take and take here and this is a
disaster with the bishops and Bishop two
to e for coming Bishop f5 in four moves
like that
so I'm this rook f2 at this rook h2
really was winning the issue though is
how do you defend here I swiped this on
d4 this is the the best possible bishop
you can have ready there's no no easy
way to see em how to defuse the attack I
f king edge a droop Queen age 4 and so
on well just compare the two pieces this
is sam this is just a huge difference
yeah thanks for watching